I want to talk to you Peter Brown about
the Consumer Electronics Show yeah first
thing that happens every year it's like
yeah january comes along okay it's gonna
be nice and quiet for games but then
suddenly all of cnet under some of the
techie people on gamespot end up going
to Vegas to see weird contraptions and
how was this year's show before we get
out really want to talk to you bout the
HTC vive specifically because I thought
your preview last week was very very
interesting but how was CES this year
kind of felt like I wasn't super
interested it wasn't super interesting
and that's a trend that's sort of in
gaining momentum in the past few years
it's hard to know why I think maybe the
the the broader innovations in gaming
you know we've sort of established those
a few years back so now what we're
seeing are these sort of new
augmentations to gaming right and VR was
one of them that was really exciting for
the past few years yeah but this year's
so much of the hardware development that
made new experience as possible has
plateaued hmm so then we're getting our
new experiences but even those new
experiences aren't really delivering
something that's terribly exciting so
for me specifically going to CES this
year felt like a letdown yeah because
nothing left me feeling like wow I can't
wait to tell everybody about that I
would easily or stuff even the VRC
really i was basically just doing my job
and I love VR you know and there are
some experiences that that really speak
to me there weren't I didn't the only
one there that that really moved me in a
way where it's like Manus is special was
something I did back in March really I
can't attribute that to a success of CES
which one was that so this is I forget
the name of it but it's essentially a
HTC vive demo where you have a palette
with a bunch of different colors you can
choose from a bunch of different brushes
and you can paint in 3d space and move
around this box and and again like pain
3d space there is a demo in by one of
the Disney artists who did the beast
from beauty and the beast and so imagine
you just have a brush and you're just
like drawing curves and you can like
change your perspective on that curve
and it just hangs in midair you can add
to it you can add effects to its cool
it's it's the sort of thing you just
lose yourself in because it feels like
magic it's not trying to take a first
person shooter or anything we know about
in relation to video games and
put that into VR it's something that is
like okay vr is different what would we
like to do with this technology like
forget everything we know start from
scratch this is a really good example of
that so let's I guess one of the cool
things about this year CES was that
yourself and Justin got to experience
oculus and the HTC five like within
minutes of each other yeah at the same
appointment indicating Vidya and it was
literally leave from one go right to the
other so I'm really interested because
most of the time there's like months
apart well that's the case so I'm very
interested here what you think or like
develop on what you said last week which
was the HTC you're actually way more
excited for that than the oculus now I'm
more excited for in terms of where I
think it's going to take VR faster hmm
because it is very much a premium
product right it's going to be more
expensive than the oculus I cannot
imagine how expensive doing is gonna be
750 yeah that's my guess because just
because of like all the extra stuff you
need well we get all the accessories
right I don't know if you get all the
accessories you don't with with your the
rift oculus you just get the headset
right you don't get that working right
HTC buddy xbox one controller to you I
mean that's that's a big deal that's
wells yeah I mean that's not a VR
accessory right that's just like a yeah
this is a regular thing yeah so but for
the the vibe you have these two
controllers that are kind of similar
Dhaka says but not without getting into
too much detail and then you have these
sensors that detect where you are in
space but the one feature that the vibe
has that you can't find on the rift is
this this magic I'd sort of camera on
the front right and what that does is
when you walk up to a wall or you're
near an object this can detect how far
away you are and it sort of creates like
a ghostly image within whatever
experience you're going doesn't like
flip to the camera it creates like a
ghostly image of what's near you so you
know like oh crap I'm about to walk into
a wall is it literally that wall but
just looks like I inspired or someplace
it's like a transparent like misty blue
that appears in your eyes okay like if I
get too close it gets bigger so it's got
pit Faisal it's like the virtual reality
version of the when you're reversing in
a car and it's beeping it's like that
thing yeah or is just a visual letting
you know yeah yeah if you're close to
and that does help the what is it sounds
like this time I think that would be an
TMR surface is putting you back into the
real world but it
well I mean let's be honest right like
if you know we're going to be doing VR
and moving in free space we have to be
cognizant in the world around us and if
you were in a game and you constantly
had a wall like a virtual wall in front
of you then you would really understand
like yeah I'm just limited to the seven
by seven space or whatever but with this
maybe you know the game can limit your
movement but you can still see in the
distance right so this gives you the
opportunity to be in a part of an
environment that's larger than you can
move in and if you happen to one or two
far at least you kind of learn your
limit right and watching that video
which was interesting because you know
it's kind of cool to see you guys being
able to move like that there was that
guy kind of holding onto the cord to
kind of make sure like hey okay like the
cable rang earlier right like yet on a
camera and whatnot so how do you view
people kind of dealing with that on
their own but can they do that on their
own I mean there were some demos that I
did I think different from the one you
saw where I was just sort of moving
around with the cable dangling behind me
and it does kind of feel like it can be
bit cumbersome hmm I think there are
mechanisms that could fix it say if you
have you know sort of in a bar with some
tension coming off your waist like some
light aluminum that just arcs it off so
it like falls at an arc behind you and
all right write down your back on your
leg to your feet that could be one
solution you know latency is really
important with VR and that's why they're
not wireless yet because the technology
just isn't there yeah but give it a few
years I'm sure companies will come up
with great solutions if not local
computing will become faster and you can
just have something on your back and I
guess the final question I have you on
this as the person who I think I
understand the most about virtual
reality in this office at least like
you've been following this for years
before any of us ever really cared and
2016 they say this is the year when the
rubber is going to hit the road like
we're not talking about VR is like this
concept anymore you know the oculus has
a price Vybz going to have like
pre-orders at the end of februari like
people are going to be able to buy this
stuff they're going to be able to have
an obvious in q1 do you think enough has
happened for it to be a big success this
year not Nate not next year do you think
there's enough happening this year or is
2016 going to be a transitional period
where people like us in the price cuts
are like play this stuff and are talking
about it or super excited but like
most folks at home are probably just
gonna be like okay I gotta wait like you
know iPad Apple watch I'll just wait a
year or two and get it down the road
yeah I mean VR has been sort of just
dating now for a few years and the way I
look at it is 2016 will be the year that
it sprouts and we begin to see signs of
you know where it's going to go both
commercially and you know as a medium
that people create things for I don't
think it'll be a big success in 2016
that is something that will come
probably five years down the road I
imagine you know PlayStation VR will be
niche HTC vive elimination some of these
things will you know maybe catch more
people's attention in special locations
like amusement parks things right that
you know I mean they kind of have to
start somewhere like we had our kids
back in the day we didn't have really
powerful gaming machines I could handle
that stuff yeah if you're sure to give
it five eight years you know the genesis
could start to you know play some arcade
ports and you know it's it's sort of
going to be that thing that that picks
up steam and before we know it it will
be that big success that is available to
all of us and a lot of the problems that
you guys are asking me about won't
really be problems at that point so
again I think it's going to be sprouting
this year and you know it will take
probably four or five years before it's
like you know we just it's an
afterthought that we just have it and we
all love it we all have our own opinions
about which is the best games and not
whether or not it'll be here or not